first of all I see this picture you had
a European vacation yeah I don't know
exactly where you links I don't know
where this picture is from but it's a
picture of you and your husband mr.
Dwyane Wade and I see this picture and I
don't know I don't know if you can see
if they get in closer there or not but
he's wearing a fanny pack kind of thing
he's wearing I mean first of all you two
look incredibly relaxed I don't know
where you are but he's got like this
purse what is it it's a man a pack Manny
pack it's a Manny pack and he's
comfortable with the man you thought is
he comfortable he is yeah he's very
probably too comfortable
he loves it in a way that is a little
uncomfortable really yeah how many of
these many packs does he have he's got
about six or seven and now like once he
started wearing them people just kept
sending them right he actually has one
that that they airbrushed murse like man
purse right sure
and we were in Paris and and James
Harden came upon his murse and he was
like who's murse is this and I was like
his murse it's my husband's murder yeah
but you know what I think a man it shows
that a man is very secure with himself
when he can carry around a Manny pack a
Manny a Manny pack a murse
yeah no he's very secure themselves and
those shorts were very shorts as long as
him you know it's amazing there he's
wearing the shorts that people in the
NBA wore when I was watching basketball
back in the 80s that is that is the
length of this short that you had to
wear back then which kept me out of the
NBA
you